يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
لان هي حرب
المنتصر فيها خاسر
[موسيقى]
بن طالب
بوقف فوري
اطلاق النار
والوصول لتفهمات تؤدي الى الوقف الدائم
للعادات
اقل تقدير يجب ان يعني نعمل على قيام هدنه
تسمح بخلق ممرات امنه تسمح للمواطنين
بانهم يقضوا حاجاتهم في الدواء
والعلاج
والمستلزمات المعيشه من غذاء الى اخره الى
اخره
وادعو
للرفض اي تدخل اجنبي في الشان السوداني
ولذلك ندعو المجتمع الدولي
يمارس الدور ايجابي لدعم
عوده الحوار السياسي
وايضا اكرر الدعوه
لقياده
الجيش
وقياده الدعم السريع
للجلوس فورا في مفاوضات
تؤدي لمعالجه وحلحله الخلافات التي ادت
لهذا الوطن
[موسيقى]
السلام هو الخيار الوحيد
المتاح للشعب السوداني
لتفادي الانزلاق
للحرب الاهليه
كلنا تابعنا
مالات الحرب الاهليه في مناطق كثيره من
اقليمنا في العالم العربي والافريقي
[موسيقى]